hurricane ida's devastating impact comes
on top of an intense coronavirus surge
in the american south reported new cases
in the state of florida have been
spiking in august and recently broke
their single day record more than 27
thousand people tested positive the
surge has hit law enforcement
particularly hard and yesterday the polk
county florida sheriff's office said
farewell to a deputy manuel pojorke
spoke with another sheriff who is also
warning one of his men
he was known as mr dependable always
asking if anyone needed a hand
orange county sheriff john mina's
department is mourning the loss of
deputy craig sehos a nearly 30-year
veteran who died from kovitt earlier
this month
the department wouldn't say whether he
was vaccinated the father of five was
only 54. talking to his family and
talking to his his fellow deputies
was hard and you could just see
the pain the hurt in their face that
pain pushed mina to record this video
message encouraging law enforcement
officers to get their shots do it so
your fellow deputies and officers can
honor you at your retirement instead of
commemorating you at your funeral
you view this vaccine as part of the
armor
it really is protection and
it's really evident that the people who
are unvaccinated are
ending up in the hospital or needing
more care around the country nearly 600
officers have died from covet 19. it was
the leading cause of death in law
enforcement last year just within the
last week the austin texas police
department lost two this funeral
procession honored another officer in
saint petersburg
an increasing number of cities including
san jose california will now require
public service employees including
police to get vaccinated or provide
proof of medical or religious exemption
some union leaders are pushing back
saying officers should be able to opt
out if they continue regular testing if
the city moves to get rid of these
officers
then we're barely hanging on right now
that's going to absolutely decimate this
police department
sheriff mina doesn't plan to make the
vaccine mandatory he says in the last
survey roughly half of his agency's
employees were vaccinated but that
number is climbing honestly
with the passing of craig i think we
have seen an uptech here and i think the
folks that you know work with him every
day and you know look at that and think
oh my gosh
maybe this could have been prevented
and the sheriff echoed the concern other
agencies have about vaccine mandates
that he could lose employees to nearby
departments that do not require them
tony
very interesting to hear that sheriff
talk about the vaccine as a kind of body
armor just like you put on your vest in
the morning before you sign up for duty
manny thank you very much